>> ANOTHER STORY LOST IN THE
MEDIA.
PRESIDENT TRUMP ANNOUNCED A PLAN
TO TIGHTEN THE ASYLUM RULES AT
THE BORDER.
MIGRANTS THAT PASS THROUGH
ANOTHER COUNTRY FIRST MUST SEEK
ASYLUM THERE RATHER THAN AT THE
BORDER.
YOU CAN'T SAY TO EL SALVADOR GET
ME OUT OF HERE WHEN YOU MEAN GET
ME A JOB IN PHOENIX.
THE PRESIDENT'S PLAN IS SIMPLE
AND SENSIBLE.
IF YOU'RE ON THE RUN FROM
SOMEBODY BAD, WHY SKIP THE FIRST
SAFE HARBOR?
IF FREDDY COUGAR IS ON YOUR TAIL
WHY GO TO THE SECOND HOUSE WITH
THE LIGHTS OFF?
THIS CHANGE IS MEANT TO PREVENT
SUFFERING BY SHORTENING THE
JOURNEY.
SO YOU THINK THE DEMS WOULD BE
ON BOARD.
NO IT'S TRUMP.
HIS IDEA OF MAKING REFUGEES SEEK
ASYLUM IN THE FIRST NEIGHBORS
THEY CAME TO IS ONE MOST
COUNTRIES USE AND FOR GOOD
REASON.
IT SAVES LIVES AS GERMANY
DISCOVERED WHEN MERKEL SAID THAT
THEY COULD GO ANYWHERE THEY
WANTED IN THE EU.
SO BRITTEN SAID TO THE EU AND
MERKEL HAS BEEN TRYING TO WALK
IT BACK.
TRUMP KNOWS WHAT PLAYS WELL ON
THE VIEW.
THIS REFORM SAYS NOT SO FAST.
IN ALL LIKELIHOOD THE DEMOCRATS
WILL HATE IT.
JUAN, FROM ONE DEMOCRAT THAT
SEEMS TO AGREE WITH THIS PLAN.
LET'S ROLL IT.
>> REFUGEE STATUS IS NOT GRANTED
JUST BASED ON ECONOMIC NEEDS OR
BECAUSE A FAMILY LIVES IN A BAD
NEIGHBORHOOD OR POVERTY.
IT'S TYPICALLY DEFINED NARROWLY.
MAY BE SOME NARROW CIRCUMSTANCES
IN WHICH THERE IS A HUMANITARIAN
OR REFUGEE STATUS THAT A FAMILY
MIGHT BE ELIGIBLE FOR.
IF THAT WERE THE CASE, IT WOULD
BE BETTER TO APPLY IN COUNTRIES
RATHER THAN TAKE A VERY
DANGEROUS JOURNEY ALL THE WAY UP
TO TEXAS.
>> I REALLY MISS HIS EXCITING
SPEECHES.
JUAN, DO YOU HATE PRESIDENT
OBAMA AND WHY?
>> YOU GOT ME.
GUILTY, YOUR HONOR.
BY THE WAY, I'M GLAD YOU PLAYED
THAT.
NOT BECAUSE HE WAS SO PEDANTIC,
SLOW THERE, BUT BECAUSE I THINK
THAT THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO AGREE.
>> RIGHT.
>> AND TO SAY HEY, YOU KNOW
WHAT?
CONGRESS AND THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
SHOULD GET TOGETHER AND CHANGE
THE ASYLUM LAW TO MAKE IT MORE
CONSISTENT, RIGHT?
THE PROBLEM IS THAT THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP NOW HAS ACTED IN
TERMS OF AN EXCESSIVE ORDER,
EXECUTIVE ACTION.
I REMEMBER WHEN PEOPLE WOULD GET
UPSET WITH OBAMA FOR TAKING THAT
KIND OF -- ISSUING EXECUTIVE
ORDERS TO TAKE ORDERS SO WHAT WE
HAVE NOW IS THE REPUBLICANS HAD
TWO YEARS OF TOTAL CONTROL OF
EVERYTHING, THE HOUSE, THE
SENATE, THE WHITE HOUSE.
DID THEY CHANGE THE ASYLUM LAW?
I DON'T THINK SO.
BUT NOW THEY'RE WILLING TO
EXPLOIT IT FOR POLITICAL GAIN.
HE DIDN'T GET THE WALL, HE
DIDN'T HAVE THE RAISE OVER THE
WEEKEND, HE DIDN'T GET THE
QUESTION ON THE CENSUS SO NOW
HE'S DOING THIS.
>> KENNEDY, YOU WANT TO RESPOND?
>> AND THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
ONE PARTY HAS ALL THE POWER.
SAME THING DEMOCRATS COMPLETELY
SCREWED UP HEALTHCARE.
WE'RE STILL PAYING THE PRICE FOR
THE FAILURE OF OBAMACARE.
THEY SHOULD HAVE TACKLED
IMMIGRATION.
WE LEARNED UNFORTUNATELY, IT'S
NOT A BIPARTISAN ISSUE.
NO PARTY IS GOING TO DO IT
EFFECTIVELY.
NO PARTY REALLY WANTS TO DO IT.
THAT'S WHY I THINK YOU'RE SEEING
SO MUCH DISTRACTION BETWEEN
NANCY PELOSI AND THE SQUAD AND
THE PRESIDENT AND THE SQUAD IS
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS PEOPLE TO NOT
WORK ON IMMIGRATION.
THEY REALLY REALLY DON'T WANT TO
DO IT.
IT'S SO INCREDIBLY UNFORTUNATE.
WE HAVE TO DEFINE THESE THINGS.
EVEN WHEN IT'S PAINFUL, EVEN
WHEN IT'S NOT POLITICALLY
CONVENIENT AND YOU DON'T SCORE
INSTANT POINTS BECAUSE SOMETIMES
FIXES ARE NOT EMOTIONAL ISSUES.
WE HAVE TO DEFINE WHAT IT MEANS
TO BE A REFUGEE AND ASYLUM.
>> THAT'S WHAT THIS BOILS DOWN
TO, EMILY, RIGHT?
SAY YES.
>> YES.
I THINK THE REALITY IS WE'RE NOT
DEALING UNDER NORMAL
CIRCUMSTANCES RIGHT NOW.
THE AVERAGE IMMIGRATION COURT
CASE IS 727 DAYS FOR IT TO BE
RESOLVED.
THAT'S OVER TWO YEARS.
SO WE NEED TO TRIAGE.
THE EXISTING LAW RIGHT NOW IS SO
CONVOLUTED.
WE SAW A LAWSUIT FILED AGAINST
THE ADMINISTRATION SAYING OKAY,
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE EXCEPTIONS
ALREADY FOR THOSE THAT HAVE GONE
THROUGH SAFE COUNTIES EXCEPT HOW
IS THAT DEFINED?
TECHNICALLY ONLY WITH CANADA,
THE MULTILATERAL OR BILATERAL
AGREEMENT.
IS IT NECESSARY FOR THE
IMMIGRANT TO HAVE RESETTLED IN
THAT COUNTRY OR PASSING THROUGH
ENOUGH.
ARE WE CREATING A COMPACT WITH
REGIONAL COMPACT WITH THE SOUTH
AMERICAN COUNTRIES?
ALL OF THESE QUESTIONS ARE IN
THE AIR.
AND WHAT THEY REQUIRE IS
DIPLOMACY AND INTERNATIONAL
RELATIONS AND ATTENTION BY
POLITICIANS AND ELECTED
OFFICIALS RATHER THAN SQUABBLING
AND FREAKING OUT THAT MOST
PEOPLE ARE DOING ON THE LEFT.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS TRIAGE NEEDS
TO OCCUR, WHICH IS WHAT THE
PRESIDENT WAS DOING BY THAT
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND THE CONTENT
OF IT ALREADY EXISTING IN OUR
EXISTING LAW.
SO IF PEOPLE HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
IT, THEY SHOULD BE WRITING OUR
SENATORS.
>> THEY'RE TRYING TO CHANGE THE
LAWS IN MEXICO AND GUATEMALA AND
THIS LEGISLATORS ARE NOT
ALLOWING THEM TO DO IT.
SO WE WON'T HAVE THOSE
AGREEMENTS ANY TIME SOON.
>> I'M GLAD JUAN AGREES THAT
NANCY HAS TO GET TOGETHER WITH
THE PRESIDENT AND CLOSE THE
ASYLUM LOOP HOLE.
I'M GLAD YOU SAID THAT.
THE PRESIDENT JUST A FEW WEEKS
AGO GAVE HER BREATHING ROOM AND
SAID I'M GOING TO HOLD BACK ON
THE ICE RAIDS IF YOU CAN GET
YOUR ACT TOGETHER ON THE ASYLUM
DEAL.
SHE DID NOTHING.
SHE WENT ON HER JULY FOURTH
BREAK AND CAME BACK AND STILL
DID NOTHING.
SEEMS TO ME THEY DON'T WANT TO
FIX IT.
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO FIX IT IN
DECEMBER WHEN THEY WERE WARNED
AND IT AND FIX IT NOW WHEN THEY
HAVE RECORD PEOPLE COMING
ACROSS.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED IN
BREXIT, THAT IS THE EXACT RESULT
OF THE MIGRATION CRISIS.
FROM THE MIGRATION CRISIS THAT
STARTED UNDER OBAMA WHEN ALL
HELL BROKE LOOSE IN SYRIA.
>> YOU CAN EXTEND IT TO THE
ELECTION OF TRUMP.
THEY'RE ALL FROM THAT --
>> SO LEARN THE LESSON.
LOOK, THEY HAD A LOT OF CRIME,
THEY HAD TERRORISM, THE RISE OF
THE RIGHT WING NATIONALIST
GROUPS AND BREXIT AS A RESULT.
SO SEEMS TO ME I DON'T THINK
THEY WANT TO STOP THE BORDER
CRISIS.